hello white welcome to this video
playing mr. serious with black so uh huh
the red team mt4 it's the most ambitious
move I'm going for that and I would like
to know it better ok it's going f1 it's
not very very critical I'm just going to
take the center here is playing
basically some kind of check benoni with
a caminho up and the tempo is not so
relevant in this in this opening ok
let's go with g3 yets a bit surprising
and oh ok
okay I'd like to go Bishop e7 but no I
have five well it's not a big deal Glen
bishop f6 that's it's possible it's very
it's a very slow way of playing I can't
even consider to take I mean it's got
very little development yeah but this is
also looking quite fine where's the
night and going next after g6 night h6
looks quite wrong and now it has no
square to go to threaten g6 winning the
night that's kind of interesting
yeah I heard guns and roses is going to
be a be a band again and they had this
line from what is that sweet ride sweet
child of mine where do you go now and
this is what i'm asking this night where
do you go now yeah this night is going
nowhere so ticket first if i take chief
i can also take g for that wins two
pawns essentially that looks that looks
actually and that looks even clearer
then grabbing the piece nigeria's Bishop
g5 and the whole position is a is a is a
disaster you can go to g3 what I take
each for then
okay so two pawns that's nice um what to
do now Stan preferable position for my
for my pieces here we should probably
hear and castles long and i would like
to prevent his his castles but will be
not working again o Queen age too maybe
provoke him I can do that provoke him to
play King f1 okay okay and it may be
Knight f6 for night h5 was better okay
it's not a not a big big big deal mmm i
still cannot cast left towards hanging
so I'm going to Castle long and just try
to play before here hmm i can check here
and before it slightly slightly annoying
if it happens how to do that let's let's
have a look Knight to f4 be good as well
like G 596 9f form I it's still not
totally conclusive or conclusive is
wrong to size surface the right word I
can also go at five I mean that opens up
his diagonal but my echo threatening F
form to to win that Bishop on h1 and
also ideas like e-40 XF form just
crashing through
yeah I bishop was a huge liability okay
um what now yo I guess
let's see that I open up open up the
position here ok and now either d three
RF form the I guess f4 is right I'm
freeing this you five square for the
night that is the idea and also allowing
g3 to come yeah so g3t xf3 maybe is
castling than 63 is able to Castle time
morning
I that isn't so clear actually hmm
be 50 that's made checkmate that's made
yeah um I didn't play that well to be
honest after the complete win here the
this position is of course totally
winning but it it was so kind of kind of
shaky probably yeah five is debatable
opening up that the diagonal but it
probably should window your voice is
actually the best move this this this
and to g3 would have would have won I
couldn't really figure out why to be
honest to this I Bishop g4 I didn't
think about that oh of course this is
very easy actually it's very easy I was
only thinking about this after which she
castles and well it's not great for
white but he kind of hangs on no
probably probably this also wins but
yeah okay that's made but i was thinking
castles and okay i can take and still
probably be winning but it requires some
some some really good moves now wow yeah
okay let's have a brief look at at the
start of the game yeah that kind of line
is I think quite unpromising for white
is essentially giving black yeah typical
white position where you have space
advantage and in general having this
this kind of formation with the
fianchetto it's not not so great in in
most cases yeah this is just a wrong
move I mean that is it's just bad here
here you can even think about taking but
it's it's it's not such a big deal
probably hear this kind of thing he's
getting in this and well that is at
least a good piece and I'm not winning
winning that porn easily this is better
trying to ask the night where it is
going and
he played this move after which it is
trapped yeah this is some g6 and yeah
maybe I should have taken the piece him
yet this is the easiest actually teak
teak and then take g5 but ok i thought i
thought i saw that i'm winning two
points with a nobleman position and went
for that and ultimately and it was ok
yeah he helped me with that would that
made it could have been could have been
so tricky i think um with the reload
time ok thanks for watching